election interference activities like
collusion coordination does not have a
settled definition and in federal
criminal law we understood coordination
to require an agreement tacit or aspre
expressed between the Trump campaign and
the Russian government on election
interference that requires more than the
two parties taking actions that were
informed or responsive to the others
actions or interests we applied the term
coordination in that sense when stating
in the report that the investigation did
not establish that the Trump campaign
coordinated with the Russian government
in its election interference activities
the report on our investigation consists
of two volumes
Volume one describes the factual results
of the special counsels investigation of
Russia's interference in the 2016
presidential election and its
interactions with the Trump campaign
section one of that volume describes the
scope of the investigation sections 2 &
3 describe the principle ways Russia
interfered in the 2016 presidential
election section 4 describes links
between the Russian government's Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign section 5 sets
forth the special counsels charging
decisions vol 2 addresses the
president's actions toward the FBI's
investigation into Russia's interference
in the 2016 presidential election and
related matters and his actions toward
the special counsels investigation vol 2
separately states its framework and the
considerations that guided that
investigation executive summary - volume
1 Russian social media campaign the
internet research agency IRA carried out
the earliest Russian interference
operations identified by the
investigation a social media campaign
designed to provoke and amplify
political and social discard in the
United States the IRA IRA was based in
Saint Petersburg Russia and received
funding from the Russian oligarch you
begged me prison for goujian sorry
and companies he controlled promotion is
widely reported to have ties to Russian
President Vladimir Putin there's then a
redacted section in mid-2014 the IRS
sent employees to the United States on
an intelligence-gathering mission with
instructions redacted the IRA later used
social media accounts and interest
groups to sow discord in the US
political system through what it termed
information warfare the campaign
involved from a generalized program
designed in 2014 and 2015 to undermine
the u.s. electoral system to a targeted
operation that by early 2016 favored
candidate Trump and disparaged candidate
Clinton the IRAs operation also included
the purchase of political advertisements
on social media in the names of US
persons and entities as well as the
staging of political rallies inside the
United States to organize those rallies
IRA employees posed as US grassroots
entities in persons and made contact
with Trump supporters and Trump campaign
officials in the United States the
investigation did not identify evidence
that any US persons conspired or
coordinated with the IRA section 2 of
this report details the offices
investigation of the Russell's Russian
social media campaign Russian hacking
operations at the same time that the IRA
operation began to focus on supporting
candidate Trump in early 2016 the
Russian government employed a second
form of interference cyber intrusions
hacking and releases of hacked materials
damaging to the Clinton campaign the
Russian intelligence service known as
the main intelligence Directorate of the
General Staff of the Russian army the
GRU carried out these operations in
March 2016 the GRU began hacking the
email accounts of Clinton campaign
volunteers and employees including
campaign chairman John Podesta in April
2016
the GRU hacked into the computer
networks of the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee
d-triple-c and the Democratic National
Committee
the DNC the GRU stole hundreds of
thousands of documents from the
compromised email accounts and networks
around the time that the DNC announced
in mid-june 2016 the Russian
government's role in hacking its network
the GRU began disseminating stolen
materials through fictitious online
personas DC leaks and gusoff ur 2.0 the
GRU later released additional materials
through the organization WikiLeaks the
presidential campaign of Donald J Trump
the Trump campaign or campaign showed
interest in WikiLeaks releases of
documents and welcomed their potential
to damage candidate Clinton beginning in
June 2016
redacted senior campaign officials that
WikiLeaks would release information
damaging to Canada Clinton WikiLeaks
first release came in June July 2016
around the same time candidate Trump
announced that he hoped Russia would
recover emails described as missing from
a private server used by Clinton when
she was Secretary of State he later said
that he was speaking sarcastically
redacting WikiLeaks began releasing
Podesta stolen emails on October 7th
2016 less than one hour after a u.s.
media outlet released video considered
damaging to candidate Trump section
three of this report details the offices
investigation into the Russian hacking
operations as well as other efforts by
Trump campaign supporters to obtain
Clinton released emails Russian contacts
with the campaign the social media
campaign and the GRU hacking operations
coincided with a series of contacts
between Trump campaign officials and
individuals with ties to the Russian
government The Office investigated
whether those contacts reflected or
resulted in the campaign conspiring or
coordinating with Russia in its election
and interference activities although the
investigation established that the
Russian government perceived it would
benefit from a trump presidency and
worked to secure that outcome
and the campaign expected it would
benefit electoral II from information
stolen and release through Russian
efforts the investigation did not
establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities the Russian
contacts consisted of business
connections offers of assistance to the
campaign invitations for candidate Trump
and Putin to meet in person invitations
for campaign officials and
representatives of the Russian
government to meet and policy positions
seeking improved us-russian relations
section 4 of the report details the
contacts between Russia and the Trump
campaign during the campaign and
transition periods the most salient of
which are summarized below in
chronological order 2015 some of the
earliest contacts were made in
connection with a trump organization
real estate project in Russia known as
Trump Tower Moscow candidate Trump
signed a letter of intent for Trump
Tower Moscow by November 2015 and in
January 2016 Trump Organization
Executive Michael Cohen emailed and
spoke about the project with the office
of Russian government press secretary
Dmitry Peskov the Trump Organization
pursued the project through at least
June 2016 including by considering
travel to Russia by Cohen and candidate
Trump spring 2016 campaign foreign
policy advisor George papadopolis made
early contact with Joseph Masood a
london-based professor who had
connections to Russia and traveled to
Moscow in April 2016 immediately upon
his return to London from that trip
we've said told Papadopoulos that the
Russian government had dirt on Hillary
Clinton in the form of thousands of
emails one week later in the first week
of May 2016 Papadopoulos suggested to a
representative of a foreign government
that the Trump campaign had received
indications from the Russian government
that it could assist the campaign
through the anonymous release of
information damaging to candidate
Clinton throughout that period of time
and for several months thereafter
Papadopoulos worked with Massoud and two
Russian national
to arrange a meeting between the
campaign and the Russian government no
meeting took place summer 2016
Russian outreach to the Trump campaign
continued into the summer of 2016 as
candidate Trump was becoming the
presumptive Republican nominee for
president on June 9 2016 for example a
Russian lawyer met with senior campaign
Trump campaign officials Donald Trump
jr. Jared Kushner and campaign chairman
Paul metaphor to deliver what the email
proposing the meeting had described as
official documents and information that
would incriminate Hillary the materials
were offered to Trump jr. as quote part
of Russia and its government's support
for mr. Trump and quote the written
communication setting up the meeting
showed that the campaign anticipated
receiving information from Russia that
could assist candidate Trump's electoral
prospects but the Russian lawyers
presentation did not provide such
information days after the June 9
meeting on June 14 2016 a cybersecurity
firm and the DNC announced that Russian
government hackers had infiltrated the
DNC and obtained access to opposition
research on candidate Trump among other
documents in July 2016 campaign foreign
policy advisor Carter page travelled in
his personal capacity to Moscow and gave
the keynote address at the New Economics
School page had lived and worked in
Russia between 2003 and 2007 after
returning to the United States page
became acquainted with at least two
Russian intelligent officers one of whom
was later charged in 2015 with
conspiracy to act as an unregistered
agent of Russia pages July 2016 trip to
Moscow and his advocacy for pro-russian
foreign policy drew media attention the
campaign then distanced itself from page
and by late September 2016 removed him
from the campaign July 16 was also the
month WikiLeaks first released emails
stolen by the GRU from the DNC on July
22nd 2016 WikiLeaks posted thousands of
internal DNC documents revealing
information
about the Clinton campaign within days
there was public reporting that US
intelligence agencies had high
confidence that the Russian government
was behind the theft of emails and
documents from the DNC and within a week
of the release a foreign government
informed the FBI about its May 2016
interaction with Papadopoulos and his
statement that the Russian government
could assist the Trump campaign on July
31st 2016 based on the foreign
government reporting the FBI opened an
investigation into potential
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign separately on
August 2 2016 Trump campaign chairman
Paul Manafort met in New York City with
his longtime business associate
konstantin columbic for the FBI assesses
to have ties to russian intelligence
clem net requested the meeting to
deliver in person a peace plan for the
Ukraine that Manafort acknowledged to
the special counsels office was a
backdoor way for Russia to control part
of eastern Ukraine both men believed the
plan would require candidate Trump's
assent to succeed where he elected to be
President they also discussed the status
of the Trump campaign and metaphors
strategy for winning Democratic votes in
Midwestern states months before that
meeting Manta Ford had caused internal
polling data to be shared with limnic
and the sharing continued for some
period of time after their August
meeting fall 2016 on October 7th 2016
the media released video of candidate
Trump speaking in graphic terms about
women years earlier which was considered
damaging to his candidacy less than an
hour later WikiLeaks made its second
release thousands of John Podesta's
emails that had been stolen by the GRU
in late March 2016 the FBI and other US
government institutions were at the time
continuing their investigation of
suspected Russian government efforts to
interfere in the presidential election
that same day October 7 the Department
of Homeland Security and the off
of the Director of National Intelligence
issued a joint public statement that the
Russian government directed the recent
compromises of emails from US persons
and institutions including from US
political organizations those thefts and
the disclosures of the hacked materials
through online platforms such as
WikiLeaks the statement continued are
intended to interfere with the u.s.
election process host 2016 election
immediately after the November 8
election Russian government officials
and prominent Russian businessman began
trying to make inroads into the new
administration the most senior levels of
the Russian government encouraged these
efforts the Russian embassy made contact
hours after the election to congratulate
the president-elect and to arrange a
call with President Putin several
Russian businessman picked up the effort
from their Herald Dimitrov the chief
executive officer of Russia sovereign
wealth fund was among the Russians who
tried to make contact with the incoming
administration in early December a
business associate steered dimitra's to
Erik Prince a supporter of the Trump
campaign and an associate of senior
Trump adviser Steve Bannon dmitriev and
Prince later met face to face in January
2017 in the Seychelles and discussed
us-russia relations during the same
period
another boat business associate
introduced a meet roof to a friend of
Jared Kushner who had not served on the
campaign or the transition team Dimitri
van Kushner's friend collaborated on a
short written reconciliation plan for
the United States and rich Russia which
dimitrov implied had been cleared
through Putin the friend gave that
proposal to Kushner before the
inauguration and Kushner later gave
copies to Bannen an incoming Secretary
of State ROCs Tillerson on December 29th
2016 then President Obama imposed
sanctions on Russia for having
interfered in the election incoming
National Security Advisor Michael Flynn
called Russian ambassador Sir Jake is
lyac and asked that Russian not to ask
Russia not to escalate the situation in
response to the sanctions the following
day Putin announced that Russia would
not take retaliatory measures in
response to the sanctions at that time
hours later president-elect Trump
tweeted great move on delay by V Putin
the next day on December 31st 2016
his Leah called Flynn and told him the
requests had been received at the
highest levels and Russia had chosen not
to retaliate as a result of Flynn's
request On January 6 2017 members of the
Intelligence Committee community briefed
president-elect Trump on a joint
assessment drafted and coordinated among
the Central Intelligence Agency
FBI and National Security Agency the
concluded with high confidence that
Russia had intervened in the election
through a variety of means to assist
Trump's candidacy and harm Clinton's a
Declassified version of that assessment
was publicly released the same day
between mid January 2017 and early
February 2017 three congressional
committees the house permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence hypsi the
Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
SSDI and the Senate Judiciary Committee
SJC announced they would conduct
inquiries or had already been conducting
inquiries into Russian interference in
the election then FBI director James
Comey later confirmed to Congress the
existence of the FBI's investigation
into Russian interference that had begun
before the election
that the FBI as part of our
counterintelligence mission is
investigating the Russian government's
efforts to interfere in the 2016
presidential election and that includes
investigating the nature of any links
between individuals associated with the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government and whether there was any
coordination between the campaign and
Russia's efforts as with any
counterintelligence investigation this
will also include an assessment of
whether any crimes were committed the
investigation continued under then
director Comey for the next seven weeks
until May 9th 2017 when President Trump
fired Comey is FBI director and action
which is in that analyzed in volume 2 of
the report on May 17 2017 acting
Attorney General rod Rosenstein
appointed the special counsel and
authorized him to conduct the
investigation that Comey had confirmed
in his congressional testimony as well
as matters arising directly from the
investigation and any other matters
within the scope of 28 CFR section six
hundred point 4 a which generally covers
efforts to interfere with or obstruct
the investigation president Trump
reacted negatively to the special
counsels appointment he told advisors
that it was the end of his presidency
sought to have attorney general
Jefferson Jeff Sessions Unruh cused from
the Russia investigation and to have the
special counsel removed and engaged in
efforts to curtail the special counsels
investigation and prevent the disclosure
of evidence to it including through
public and private contacts with
potential witnesses those and related
actions are described and analyzed in
volume 2 of the report the special
counsels charging decisions in reaching
the charging decision decisions
described in volume 1 of the report the
office determined whether the conduct it
found amounted to a violation of federal
criminal law chargeable under the
principles of federal prosecution see
justice manual section 9 - 27 at SEC
2018 the standard set forth in the
justice manual
whether the conduct constitutes a crime
if so whether admissible evidence would
probably be sufficient to obtain and
sustain a conviction and whether
prosecution would serve a substantial
federal interest that could not
adequately be served by prosecution
elsewhere or through non criminal
alternatives
see justice manual section 9 - 27.2 2o
section 5 of the report provides
detailed explanation of the offers
offices charging decisions which contain
three main components first the office
determined that Russia's two principal
interference operations in the 2016 US
presidential election the social media
campaign and the hacking and dumping
operations violated US criminal law many
of the individuals and entities involved
in the social media campaign have been
charged with participating in a
conspiracy to defraud the United States
by undermining through deceptive acts
the work of federal agencies charged
with regulating foreign influence in
u.s. elections as well as related counts
of identity theft see United States vs
Internet research agency at all number
18 - CR - 32 D DC separately Russian
intelligence officers who carried out
the hacking into democratic party
computers and the personal email
accounts of individuals affiliated with
the Clinton campaign conspired to
violate among other federal laws the
federal computer intrusion statute and
they have been so charged C United
States vs myth net disco at all number
18 - C issues are I'm sorry
number 18 - CR - 215 DD C then there's a
redacted portion second while the
investigation identified numerous links
between individuals with ties to the
Russian government and individuals
associated with the Trump campaign the
evidence was not sufficient to support
criminal charges among other things the
evidence was not sufficient to charge
any campaign official as an unregistered
agent of the Russian government or other
Russian principle and our evidence about
the June 9 2016
meeting and the wiki Lisa's really wiki
leaks releases of hacked materials was
not sufficient to charge a criminal
campaign finance violation further the
evidence was not sufficient to charge
that any member of the Trump campaign
conspired with representatives of the
Russian government to interfere in the
2016 election third the investigation
established that several individuals
affiliated with the Trump campaign lied
to the office and to Congress about
their interactions with Russia
affiliated individuals and related
matters those lies materially impacted
the investigation of Russian election
interference the office charged some of
those lies as violations of the federal
fault statement statute former national
security adviser Michael Flynn pleaded
guilty to lying about his interactions
with Russian ambassador his lyac during
the transition period george papadapolis
a foreign policy advisor during the
campaign period pleaded guilty to lying
to investigators about inter alia the
nature and timing of his interactions
with Joseph Masood the professor who
told Papadopoulos that the Russians had
dirt on candidate Clinton in the form of
thousands of emails former Trump
Organization attorney Michael Cohen
pleaded guilty to making false
statements to Congress about the Trump
Moscow project and there's a redacted
portion and in February 2019 the US
District Court for the District of
Columbia found that man afford lied to
the office in the grand jury concerning
his interactions and communications with
Konstantin limnic about the Trump
campaign polling data and a peace plan
for Ukraine the office investigated
several other events that have been
publicly reported to involve potential
Russia related contacts for example the
investigation established that
interactions between Russian ambassador
his lyac and Trump campaign officials
both at the candidates April 2016
foreign policy speech in Washington DC
and during the week of the Republican
National Convention were brief public
and non substantive and the
investigation did not establish that one
campaign effete officials efforts to
dilute a portion of the Republican party
platform on providing assistance to
Ukraine were undertaken at the Bell
of candidate Trump or Russia the
investigation also did not establish
that a meeting between kiss Lea
concessions in September 2016 at
sessions Senate office included any more
than a passing mention of the
presidential campaign the investigation
did not always yield admissible
information or testimony or a complete
picture of the activities undertaken by
the subjects of the investigation some
individuals invoke their Fifth Amendment
right against compelled
self-incrimination and were not in the
offices judgment appropriate candidates
for grants of immunity the office
limited its pursuit of other witnesses
information such as information known to
attorneys or individuals claiming to be
members of the media in light of
internal Department of Justice policies
see eg justice manual sections 9 - 13
413 that point 4 10 some of the
information obtained via court process
moreover was presumptively covered by
legal privilege and was screened from
investigators by a filter or taint team
even when individuals testified or
agreed to be interviewed they sometimes
provided information that was false were
incomplete leading to some of the false
statement charges described above and
the office faced practical limits on its
ability to access relevant invitation
evidence as well numerous witnesses and
subjects lived abroad and documents were
held outside the United States further
the office learned that some of the
individuals we interviewed or whose
conduct we investigated including some
associated with the Trump campaign
deleted relevant communications or
communicated during the relevant time
period using applications that feature
encryption or they do not provide for
long term retention of data or
communications records in such cases the
office was not able to corroborate
witness statements through comparison to
contemporaneous communications or fully
question witnesses about statements that
appeared inconsistent with other known
facts accordingly while this report
embodies factual and legal
determinations that the office believes
to be accurate and complete to the
greatest extent
given these identified gaps the office
cannot rule out the possibility that the
unavailable information would shed
additional light on or cast in a new
light the events described in the report
section one the special counsels
investigation on May 17 2017 Deputy
Attorney General Rod J Rosenstein then
serving as Acting Attorney General for
the Russia investigation following the
recusal of former attorney general Jeff
sessions on March 2nd 2016 appointed the
special counsel to investigate Russian
interference with the 2016 presidential
election and related matters office of
the Deputy Attorney General Order number
3 950 2017 appointment of special
counsel to investigate Russian
interference with the 2016 presidential
election and related matters May 17 27
teen hereinafter called the appointment
order relying on the authority vested in
the acting Attorney General including 28
USC sections 509 510 and 515 the acting
Attorney General ordered the appointment
of a special counsel in order to
discharge the acting Attorney General's
responsibility to provide supervision
and management of the Department of
Justice and to ensure a full and
thorough investigation of the Russian
government's efforts to interfere in the
2016 presidential election appointment
order introduction the special counsel
the order stated is authorized to
conduct the investigation confirmed by
then FBI director James B Comey in
testimony before the house permanent
Select Committee on Intelligence on may
20th 2017 including number one any links
or coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the campaign of President Donald
Trump and number two any matters that
arose or may arise directly from the
investigation and number three any other
matters within the scope of 28 CFR
section 600 point four a appointment
order
paragraph B Section six hundred point
four affords the Special Counsel the
authority to investigate and prosecute
federal crimes committed in the course
of and with the intent to interfere
the special counsels investigation such
as perjury obstruction of justice
destruction of evidence and intimidation
of witnesses 28 CFR section 600 point
for a the authority to investigate any
matters that arose directly from the
investigation appointment order
paragraph b2 covers several similar
crimes that may have occurred during the
course of the FBI's confirmed
investigation before the special
counsels appointment if the special
counsel believes it is necessary and
appropriate the order further provided
the special counsel is authorized to
prosecute federal crimes arising from
the investigation of these matters heed
paragraph C finally the acting Attorney
General made applicable section six
hundred point four through six hundred
point ten of title 28 of the Code of
Federal Regulations it at paragraph D
the acting Attorney General further
clarified the scope of the special
council's investigate or authority in
two subsequent memoranda a memorandum
dated August to 2017 explained that the
appointment order had been worded
categorically in order to permit its
public release without confirming
specific investigations involving
specific individuals it then confirmed
that the special counsel had been
authorized since his appointment to
investigate allegations that three Trump
campaign officials Carter page Paul
Manafort and George papadopolis
committed a crime or crimes by colluding
with Russian government officials with
respect to the Russian government's
efforts to interfere with the 2016
presidential election the memorandum
also confirmed the special counsels
authority to investigate certain other
matters including two additional sets of
allegations involving met afford crimes
arising from payments you received from
the Ukrainian government and crimes
arising from his receipt of loans from a
bank whose CEO was then seeking a
position in the Trump administration
allegations that path LEDApple is
committed a crime or crimes by acting as
an unregistered agent of the Israeli
government and four sets of allegations
involving Michael Flynn the former
national security adviser to President
Trump on October 20th 2017 the acting
Attorney General confirmed in a
memorandum
the special counsels investigative
authority as to several individual ease
individuals and entities first as part
of a full and thorough investigation of
the Russian government's efforts to
interfere in the 2016 presidential
election the special counsel was
authorized to investigate the pertinent
activities of michael cohen richard
gates redacted Roger stone and redacted
confirmation of that authorization to
investigate such individuals the
memorandum stressed does not suggest
that the special counsel has made a
determination that any of them has
committed a crime second with respect to
Michael Cohen the memorandum recognized
the special counsels authority to
investigate leads related to Cohen's
establishment and use of essential
consultants LLC to inter alia receive
funds from Russian backed entities third
the memorandum are memorialized the
special counsels authority to
investigate individuals and entities
were possibly engaged in jointly
undertaken activity with existing
subjects of the investigation including
Paul Manafort finally the memorandum
described an FBI investigation opened
before the special counsels employment
into allegations that then Attorney
General Jeff sessions made false
statements to the United States Senate
and confirm the special counsels
authority to investigate that matter the
special counsel structured the
investigation in view of his power and
authority to exercise all investigative
and prosecutorial functions of any
United States Attorney 28 CFR 600 point
six like a US Attorney's Office the
special counsel's office considered a
range of classified and unclassified
information available to the FBI in the
course of the offices Russia
investigation and the office structured
that work around evidence for possible
use in prosecutions of federal crimes
assuming that one or more crimes were
identified that warranted prosecution
there was substantial evidence
immediately available to the Special
Counsel at the inception of the
investigation in May 2017 because the
FBI had by that time already
investigated Russian election
interference for nearly 10 months a
special counsels office exercised its
judgment regarding what to investigate
and did not for instance investigate
every public report of a contact between
the Trump campaign and Russia affiliated
individuals and entities
thank you very much
the office has concluded the office has
concluded its investigation into links
and coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign certain
proceedings associated with the offices
work remain ongoing after consultation
with the office of the Deputy Attorney
General the office has transferred
responsibility for those remaining
issues to other components of the
Department of Justice and FBI appendix D
lists those transfers to district courts
confirmed the breadth of the special
counsels authority to investigate Russia
into election interference and links and
a coordination with the Trump campaign
the United States vs Man afford the
United States vs Man afford in the
course of conducting that investigation
the office periodically identified
evidence of potential criminal activity
that was out skyed this that was outside
the scope of the special counsels
authority established by the acting
Attorney General after consultation with
the office of the Deputy Attorney
General the office referred to that
evidence to appropriate law enforcement
authorities principally other components
of the Department of Justice and to the
FBI appendix D summarizes those
referrals to carry out the investigation
and prosecution of the matters assigned
to him the Special Counsel assembled a
team that at its high point included 19
attorneys five of whom joined the office
from private practice and 14 on detail
or assigned from other Department of
Justice components these attorneys were
assisted by a filter team of Department
lawyers and FBI personnel who screened
materials obtained by a court process
for privileged information before
turning those materials over to
investigators they support staff of
three paralegals on detail from the
department's Antitrust Division and the
administrative staff of nine responsible
for budget finance purchasing Human
Resources records facility security
information technology and
administrative support the special Cal
so attorneys and the sports staff were
co-located with and we're excited and
worked alongside approximately 40 FBI
agents intelligence analysts forensic
accountants a paralegal and professional
staff assigned by the FBI to assist a
special counsels investigation those
assigned FBI employees remained under
FBI supervision at all times the matters
on which they assisted was supervised by
the special counsel during its
investigation the office issued more
than 2,800 subpoenas under the auspices
of a grand jury sitting in the District
of Columbia executed nearly 500 search
and seizure warrants obtained more than
230 orders for communications records
under 18 USC 2 2703 D obtained almost 50
orders authorizing use of pen registers
made 13 requests to foreign governments
pursuant to mutual legal assistance
treaties and interviewed approximately
500 witnesses including almost 80 before
a grand jury from its inception the
office recognized that its investigation
could identify foreign intelligence and
counterintelligence information relevant
to the FBI's broader national security
mission FBI personnel who assisted the
office established procedures to
identify and convey such information to
the FBI the FBI's counterintelligence
division met with the office regularly
for that purpose for most of the
officers tenure for more than the past
year the FBI also embedded personnel at
the office who did not work on the
special counsels investigation but whose
purpose was to review the results of the
investing
you
Communications and other correspondence
between the office and the FBI contained
information derived from the
investigation not all of which is
contained in this volume this volume is
a summary it contains in the officers
judgment that information necessary to
account for the special counsels
prosecution and declination decisions
and to describe the investigations main
factual results the first form of
Russian election influence came
principally from the internet research
agency LLC IRA a Russian organization
funded by Afghani Viktorovich prigogine
and companies he controlled including
Concord management and consulting LLC
and Concord catering collectively
Concord the IRA conducted social media
operations targeted at large US
audiences with the goal of sowing
discord in the US political system these
operations constituted active measures a
term that typically refers to operations
conducted by Russian security services
aimed at influencing the course of
international affairs the IRA and dis
employees began operations targeting the
United States as early as 2014
using fictitious u.s. personas IRA
employees operated social media accounts
and group pages designed to attract US
audiences these groups and accounts
which address divisive US political and
social issues falsely claimed to be
controlled by US activists over time
these social media accounts became a
means to reach large US audiences IRA
employees traveled to the United States
in mid-2014 an intelligence gathering
mission to obtain information and
photographs for use in their social
media posts IRA employees posted
derogatory information about a number of
candidates in the 2016 US presidential
election by early to mid 2016 IRA
operations included supporting the Trump
campaign and disparaging candidate
Hillary Clinton the IRA made various
expenditures to carry on the out of
these activities including buying
political
participants on social media and the
names of us persons and entities some
IRA employees posing as US persons and
without revealing the Russian
Association communicate electronically
with individuals associated with the
Trump campaign and with other political
activists to seek to coordinate
political activities including the
staging of political rallies the
investigation did not identify evidence
that any US persons knowingly or
intentionally coordinated with the IRAs
interference operation by the end of the
2016 US election the IRA had the ability
to reach millions of US persons through
their social media accounts multiple IRA
controlled Facebook groups and Instagram
accounts had hundreds of thousands of US
participants IRA controlled Twitter
account separately had tens of thousands
of followers including multiple US
political figures who retweeted IRA
created content in November 2017 a
Facebook representative testified that
Facebook had identified 470 IRA
controlled Facebook accounts they
collectively made 80,000 posts between
January 2015 in August 2017 Facebook
estimated the IRA reached as many as 126
million persons through its Facebook
accounts in January 2018 Twitter
announced that it had had identified
3814 IRA controlled Twitter accounts
notified approximately 1.4 million
people Twitter belief may have been in
contact with the IRA controlled account
hey structure of the internet research
agency redacted the organization quickly
grew redacted the growth of the
organization also led to more detailed
organizational structure redacted
redacted to individuals head of the IRS
management its general director Mikhail
bist rub and his executive director
mikhail bertrand redacted ezra as early
as the spring of 2014 the IRA began to
hide his funding and activities redacted
he I erased US operations are part of a
larger set of interlocking operations
known as project locked out
redacted be fun
an oversight from Concord and Prigogine
until at least February 2018 you have
Kenny Viktorovich priori Goshen and to
Concord companies what funded the IRA
prigogine is a wealthy Russian
businessman who served as the head of
Concorde redacted Prigogine was
sanctioned by the US Treasury Department
in December 2016 redacted numerous media
sources have reported the news oceans
ties to Putin and the two have appeared
together in public photographs redacted
redacted redacted redacted redacted
redacted redacted IRA employees were
aware that prigogine was involved in the
IRAs u.s. operations redacted in May
2016
IRA employees claiming to the u.s.
social activists and administrators of
Facebook groups recruited us persons to
hold signs including one in the front of
the White House that read happy birth
happy 55th he happy 55th birthday dear
boss as an homage to brie goujian whose
55th birthday was on june 1st 2016
redacted redacted see the IRA targets US
elections 1 the IRA ramps up US
operations as early as 2014 the IRAs US
operations sought to influence public
opinion through online media and forums
by the spring of 2014 the IRA began to
consolidate US operations within a
single general department known
internally as the translator Department
redacted IRA subdivided the translated
department into different
responsibilities ranging from operations
on different social media platforms
analytics to graphics and IT redacted
redacted redacted redacted redacted
redacted exactly redacted redacted
redacted IRA employees also travel to
the United States on intelligence
gathering missions in June 2014 for IRA
employees applied to the US Department
of State to enter the United States
while lying about the purpose of their
trip and claiming into the
friends who had met at a party
ultimately two IRA employees Anna bogut
Sheva and Alexandra karlova received
visas and into the United States on June
4th 2014 prior to traveling karlova and
boga Sheva compiled itineraries and
instructions for the trip redacted
redacted to US operations through IRA
controlled social media accounts
dozens of IRA employees were responsible
for operating accounts and personas on
different US social media platforms the
IRA referred to employees assigned to
operate their social media accounts as
quote specialists starting as early as
2014 the IRA as US operations included
social media specialists focusing on
Facebook YouTube and Twitter the IRA
later added specialists who operated on
Tumblr and Instagram accounts initially
the IRA created social media accounts
that pretended to be the personal
accounts of US persons by early 2015 the
ra began to create largest social media
groups or public social media pages that
claimed falsely to be affiliated with US
political and grassroots organizations
in certain cases the IRA created
accounts that mimics real US
organizations for example one IRA
controlled the Twitter account at ten
GOP purported to be connected to this
Tennessee Republican Party well commonly
the IRA created accounts of the names of
fictitious viewers organizations in
grassroots groups and use these accounts
to pose as anti-immigration groups Tea
Party activists black lives matter
protesters and other US social and
political activists the IRA closely
monitored the activity of its social
media accounts redacted redacted
redacted by February 2016 infernal IRA
documents preferred to support for the
Trump campaign in opposition to
candidate Clinton for example redacted
directions to IRA operators redacted
main idea use any opportunity to
criticize Hillary Clinton and the rest
except Sanders and Trump we support them
redacted the focus on the u.s.
presidential campaign
continue throughout 2016 in redacted
2016 internal redacted reviewing the the
IRA controlled Facebook Facebook group
secured borders the author criticized
the lower number of posts dedicated to
criticizing Hillary Clinton and reminded
the Facebook specialist it is imperative
to intensify criticism in criticizing
Hillary Clinton IRA employees also
acknowledge that their work focused on
influencing the u.s. presidential
election redacted three US operations
through Facebook
many IRA operations use Facebook
accounts created and operated by its
specialists redacted redacted redacted
redacted redacted redacted IRA Facebook
groups acted during the 2016 campaign
covered a range of political issues and
included purported conservative groups
with names such as being patriotic stop
oil immigrants secured borders and tea
party news purported black social
justice groups black America black
matters black tourists and don't shoot
us LGBTQ groups LGBT United and
religious groups United Muslims of
America throughout 2016
IRA accounts published an increasing
number of materials supporting the Trump
campaign and opposing the Clinton
campaign for example on May 31st 2016
the operational account mattis Guyver
began to privately message dozens
approach from Facebook groups asking
them to help plan approach rump rally
near trump tower to reach larger US
audiences the IRA purchased
advertisements from Facebook that
promised the IRA groups on the that
promoted the IRA groups on the news
feeds of us audience members according
to Facebook the IRA purchased over 3,500
advertisements and the expenditures
totaled approximately $100,000
during the u.s. presidential campaign
many IRA purchased and advertisements
explicitly supported or opposed to
presidential candidate or promoted us
rallies organized by the IRA discussed
below as early as March 2016 the IRA
purchased advertisements that overtly
opposed the Clinton campaign for example
March 18 2016 the IRA purchased an
advertisement depicting Klan today
Clinton and a caption that read in part
well if one day guard lets this liar
into the White House as the president
that day would be a real national
tragedy
similarly on April 6 2016 the IRA
purchased advertisements for its account
of black matters calling for a flash mob
of us verses to quote
take a photo with Hillary Clinton or
prison 2016 or no Hillary 2016 I already
purchased advertisements featuring
Clinton were with very few exceptions
negative IRA purchased advertisements
referring referencing candidate Trump
largely supported his campaign the
first-known IRA advertisement explicitly
endorsing the Trump campaign was
purchased in April 19 2016 he are a
bought an advertisement for its
Instagram account quote tea party news
of close quote asking us persons to help
them quote make a patriotic team of
young Trump supporters by uploading
photos with a hashtag kids for Trump
it's in subsequent months the IRA
purchased dozens of advertisements
supporting the Trump campaign
predominantly through the Facebook
groups of being patriotic stop all
invaders and secured borders
collectively the IRA social media
accounts reach tens of millions of US
persons individual IRA social media
accounts attracted hundreds of thousands
of followers for example at the time
they were deactivated by Facebook in mid
2017 the IRAs United Muslims of America
Facebook group had over 300,000
followers that don't shoot us Facebook
group and over 250,000 followers the
being patriotic Facebook group at over
200,000 followers in squirters Facebook
group and over 130,000 followers
according to Facebook in total the IRA
controlled accounts made over 80,000
posts before their descent deactivation
in August 2017 and these post reached at
least 29 million u.s. persons and may
have reached an estimated 126 million
people for US operations through Twitter
a number of the IRA employees assigned
to the translated Department served as
Twitter specialist
redacted the I erase Twitter operations
involve two strategies first IRA
specialists operated certain Twitter
accounts to create individual us
personas redacted separately the IRA
operated a network of automated Twitter
accounts commonly referred to as a bot
network and enabled the IRA to amplify
existing content on Twitter Hey
individualized accounts redacted the IRA
operated individualized Twitter accounts
similar to the operation of its Facebook
accounts by continuously posting
original content to the accounts while
also communicating with us Twitter users
directly through public tweeting or
Twitter's private messaging the IRA used
many of these accounts to attempt to
influence us audiences on the election
individualized accounts used to
influence the u.s. presidential election
included hashtag ten GOP described above
hashtag gen Abrams claiming to be a
Virginian trump supporter with seventy
thousand followers hashtag pamela more
thirteen claiming to be a texan trump
supporter with seventy thousand
followers and hashtag america first an
anti-immigration persona with twenty
four thousand followers in May 2016 the
IRA created the Twitter accounts
hashtag March for Trump which promoted
IRA organized rallies in support of the
Trump campaign baseball team
it was
using these accounts and others the IRA
provoked reactions from users in the
media multiple IRA posts and tweets
gained popularity US media outlets also
quoted tweets from IRA control to
counseling tributed them to the
reactions of real US persons similarly
numerous high-profile US persons
including former ambassador Michael
McFaul Roger stone Sean Hannity and
Michael Flynn jr. retweeted or responded
to tweets posted to these IRA controlled
accounts multiple individuals affiliated
with the Trump campaign also promoted
IRA tweets discussed below be IRA botnet
activities redacted redacted redacted in
January 2018 Twitter publicly identified
3814 Twitter accounts associated with
the IRA according to Twitter in the ten
weeks before the 2016 US presidential
election these accounts posted
approximately 175,000 993 tweets quote
approximately 8.4 percent of which will
at truth were election related close
quote Twitter also announced that they
notified approximately 1.4 million
people who Twitter believe may have been
in contact with an IRA controlled
account five US operations involving
political rallies the IRA organized and
promoted political rallies inside the
United States while posing as US
grassroots activists first the IRA is
one of its pre-existing social media
personas Facebook groups and Twitter
accounts for example to announce and
promote the event the IRA then sent a
large number of direct messages to
followers of its social media account
asking them to attend the event from
those who responded with interest in
attending the IRA then sought a u.s.
person to serve as the events
coordinator in most cases the IRA
account operator would tell the US
person that they personally could not
attend the event due to some
pre-existing conflict or because they
were somewhere else the United States
the IRA then further promoted the event
by contacting US media about the event
and directing them to speak with the
coordinator after the event the IRA
posted videos and photographs of the
event to the IRAs
to media accounts
identified dozens of US rallies
organized by the IRA the earliest
evidence of a rally was a quote
Confederate rally unquote in November of
2015 the IRA continued to organize
rallies even after the 2016 US
presidential election the attendance at
rallies varied the rallies some rallies
appeared to have drawn few if any
participants while others drew hundreds
the reach and success of these rallies
was closely monitored and then there's a
section deleted harm to ongoing matter
and then the next page is is also
entitled harm to ongoing matter then at
the top of page 31 from June 2016 until
the end of the presidential campaign
almost all of the US rallies organized
by the IRA focused on the u.s. election
often promoting the Trump campaign in
opposing the Clinton campaign quote pro
Trump rallies included three in New York
a series of proton rallies in Florida in
August 2016 and a series of proton
rallies in October 2016 in Pennsylvania
the Florida rallies drew the attention
of the Trump campaign which posted about
the Miami rally on candidate Trump's
Facebook account as discussed below many
of the same IRA employees who oversaw
the IRAs social media accounts also
conducted the day-to-day recruiting for
political rallies inside the United
States and the next section is deleted
harm to ongoing matter six targeting and
recruitment of US persons as early as
2014 the IRA instructed its employees to
target US persons
who could be used to advance its
operational goals initially recruitment
focused on us persons who could amplify
the content posted by the IRA and the
next two parts are deleted saying
indicating harm to ongoing matter IRA
employees frequently used and then this
section deleted investigative technique
then continues with Twitter Facebook and
Instagram to contact and recruit us
persons who followed the group the IRA